welcome back to uncensored live from New
York City Donald Trump has sounded well
most presidential in recent
proclamations calling for Unity in the
party and the country that may have
broader appeal in presidential election
than the vengeful election denying rants
we become accustomed to but can it last
which Trump is running for president the
unifier or the divider here to hopefully
shed some light is one of his biggest
supporters who also got a shout out in
his Iowa victory speech the Arizona
Senate candidate and friend of the show
Carrie Lake Carrie good to see you how
are you it's great to be back thank you
for having me on today Pierce well you
just heard a very good pitch for why
Nikki Haley uh is in a two-horse race
now with Donald Trump and he made a
compelling argument I think Governor
sonunu that if you look at the path of
New Hampshire and South Carolina you got
to say it favors her over DeSantis do
you agree with him this couldn't end up
quite quickly as a two-horse race you
know I think we're going through some
formalities I think president Trump is
already the nominee and uh the American
people understand that but it's it's a
little bit of an ego trip for um for the
others and a vanity project and I guess
we just have to wait until they come to
grips with reality that President Trump
will be the nominee and he's going to
lead us back to our greatest days here
in America with a secure border and a
great economy and frankly World Peace
which I think the whole world will
benefit from are we going to get the
Trump that we heard in his Iowa victory
speech which was far more unifying he's
very comp complimentary about his Rivals
he was very unifying in his language
about bringing Independence and
Democrats together with Republicans
which is what a lot of average Americans
I think are crying out for an enter the
toxic tribalism and a more unified
country is that the Donald Trump we may
see if you want a second term do you
think I I think we will see that and you
know I didn't hear that from the others
that were running in their speeches on
Monday night they were very much still
attacking president Trump and and his uh
the folks who support him but president
Trump does want to bring this country
together I talked to him quite often and
in his policies he did bring this
country together you have to remember
when he was President Pierce we had an
incredible economy we had the lowest
unemployment rate in the entire time
I've been alive and that means
unemployment rates were low for black
Americans Latino Americans
asian-americans white Americans his
policies were unifying because they
helped improve the lives of all
Americans and we had a secure border we
weren't being overw with people invading
our our country illegally coming into
our country and uh taking away from
Americans who are many of them homeless
on the streets and we're watching right
now as Joe Biden continues to put the
needs of people who' come here illegally
ahead of American citizens so Trump will
put the American people first what if
he's in prison I mean genuine question
he's facing 91 criminal charges what if
he's convicted
of one or some of those charges and
actually gets put into a prison cell I
mean it could happen under the
Constitution he would still be able to
run the country but would that be a good
thing we've seen the witch hunts they've
been going on since president Trump had
the courage to step into the political
Arena there's been one Witch Hunt after
the next and most of it fueled by the
media sadly and even if he was sitting
in Alcatraz the people will vote for him
because they know that he is going going
to put America First and in the last
three years under Joe Biden we've
watched as America has been put last
we've learned how he's taken payouts and
bribes from um some of our adversaries
and we are all suffering because of it
and we just want to get policies back
that put our country first strengthen
our families strengthen our border and
strengthen our security and us a decent
energy policy here's the problem I wrote
a column yesterday uh in which I extol
the landslide Victory it was it was
spectacular it's an amazing in comeback
story on furling with Donald Trump but
in the weeds of some of the data were
some concerning numbers like 30% of
Republicans when are said that they
would not support him if he was
convicted of a crime that's a big number
of Republicans you got to assume that
percentage would go up with Independence
who would be crucial to him potentially
winning a general election are you not
concerned about that I mean it may well
be as you say all a liberal Witch Hunt
um or it may not but if he's actually
convicted it does seem like many
Republicans would be deterred and may
prefer to then pivot to another
candidate well you're always going to
have those Republicans who have Trump
derangement syndrome and I think they
will eventually start to come around as
we get closer to the election I've
looked at the polls actually I've been
following them very closely and
president Trump is the only Republican
who can win and can beat um Biden or
whomever they put forth as their
candidate the others can't win and
you've got to have have the Trump
supporters behind you to get a victory
and the Trump supporters uh dedication
to president Trump because they know
that he's helped us they know that he's
put us first his support is a mile deep
these other guys support is about an
inch deep and it won't
last if he wants to win a general
election why should any of us accept the
result why shouldn't we just all pull a
trump and say no not having it never
happened the other guy got Biden got
stolen got robbed and just keep saying
that for the entire tenure of Trump's
second term I mean seriously why
shouldn't Americans just not me but
Americans just return the favor yeah we
heard that in 2016 remember Hillary um
was the original election denier that's
the term they use we've all been called
that and this is one of the reasons
Pierce why I've been pushing and working
really hard to bring about election
reform because frankly since 2000 we've
had elections where one year it'll be
the Democrats saying they don't think it
was fair the next time it's the
Republicans we have the ability to make
our election so fair that we wake up the
next day after the election and everyone
can live with the results because they
know it was fair and that's why I
continue to push to try to reform our
elections so that Democrats feel
comfortable and believe in the results
Independents and Republicans and I think
pres car we we we've debated this before
but my problem with that is to any
independent eye they have been Fair your
election Trump's election uh they were
fair and most senior Republicans have
accepted this and to continue bleeting
about having an election Rob makes it
difficult for you to then claim victory
doesn't it in elections well I I will
point out that I um you brought up the
whole topic so it was your topic that
you brought up and asked me about and I
just answered so I think we're going to
work to bring about reform I mean I
think more and more Americans are
realizing that u mail in ballots and
having them float around out there for a
month and voting for a month and
Counting votes for two weeks is a is a
recipe for fraud to seep into our
elections and I think all we want is
really fair elections that everybody
feels comfortable
with